good morning my name is dr. gears and I
will be taking your lecture today please
sit down and listen
they are CP we are going to be studying
today is SCP 87 object class Euclid
special containment procedures SCP 87 is
located on the campus of the doorway
leading to a CPA t7 is constructed of
reinforced steel with an electro release
lock mechanism and has been disguised to
resemble a janitorial closet
consistent with the design of the
building the lock mechanism on the
doorknob will not release unless it's
volts are applied in conjunction with
counterclockwise rotation of the key
inside the door is lined with six
centimeters of industrial foam padding
due to the results of the final
exploration no personnel are permitted
access to a CP 87 description SCP 87 is
an unlit platform staircase the stairs
descend on a 38 degree angle for 13
steps before reaching a semicircular
platform for proximately three meters in
diameter descent direction rotates 180
degrees at each platform the design of
SCP 87 limits subjects visual range to
approximately 1.5 flights a light source
is required for any subjects exploring
SCP 87 as there are no lighting fixtures
or windows present lighting sources
brighter than 75 Watts have shown to be
ineffective as SCP 87 seems to absorb
excess light subjects report and audio
recordings confirm the distressed
vocalizations promoters to be a child
between the ages and the source of the
distress calls is estimated to be
located approximately 200 metres below
the initial platform however and he
attempts to descend the staircase have
failed to bring subjects closer to the
source the depth of the descent
calculated from exploration for the long
exploration is sure to be far beyond
both the possible structure of both the
building and the geological surroundings
at this time it is unknown if SCP 87 has
an end point SCP 87 has undergone for
video recorded explorations by d-class
personnel each subject conducting an
exploration has encountered SCP 87 - one
which appears as a face with no visible
pupils nostrils or mouth the nature of
SCP 87 - one is entirely unclear but it
has been determined that it is not the
source of the pleading subjects exhibit
feelings of intense paranoia and fear
when faced with a CP 87 - 1 but it is
undetermined whether said feelings are
abnormal or simply natural reactions
addendum over a period of two weeks
following exploration for several
members of staff and students from the
campus reported knocking at a variable
rate of one to two seconds per knock
coming from the interior of SCP 87 the
door leading to scp-871 fitted with a
six centimeter thick industrial padding
all reports of knocking have ceased this
is document 87 - one
could you please describe the sound
[Music]
[Music]
please continue you've spent a long time
in a darkened stairwell it's natural
please continue
[Music]
and this is document 87 - please
continue
thank you please proceed can you please
describe what you see thank you please
continue please continue
[Music]
d-9035
[Music]
unfortunately document 3 was completely
corrupted in transit today so I'll be
going through exactly what happened as
the transcript of the recording is still
available date 9 double 8 4 is a 23 year
old female of average build and
appearance psychological background
indicates a history of depression
subject has a minimal record of using
excessive force to do d9 double 8 4 is
equipped with a 75 watt flood lamp with
a battery power capable of lasting 24
hours
a handheld camcorder fitted with a
transmission stream and an audio headset
for communication with dock at control D
9 double 8 4 is also equipped with a
backpack containing 3 point 7 5 liters
of water 15 nutrient pars and 1 thermal
blanket D 9 double 8 4 stands on the
ground level landing of SCP 87 flood
lamp illuminates only the first 9 steps
LED lights placed on the ward during the
last exploration are not visible d9
double 8 4 descends 13 steps and stops
at the landing there is no trace of the
LED light at the location footage from
exploration to indicates it was placed
she mentions the walls being dirty and
them being sticky d9 double 8 4
indicates the spot on the wall the LED
light should have been located
deena and double 8 4 notes she can hear
a child crying begging for help
d9 double 8 4 descends upon reaching the
next landing audio the crying child
consistent with the prior two
explorations is picked up no LED lights
appear to be present on any of the
landing walls d9 double a for continues
with no incident until she reaches the
17th landing
Dean and uh blade for notes there was
something on the ground and it smells
bad
apparently sticky and it has stuck to
her shoe video feed confirms the
presence of substance occupying a space
approximately 50 centimeters in diameter
and dot asks her to describe the scent D
9 double 8 4 responds by saying it
smells like old rusty metal and urine D
9 double 8 for continues to the 51st
landing without incident the 51st
landing remains unchanged from the
previous expedition and similar
observations are made D 9 double 8 4 is
asked again to descend until anything
unusual is noticed subject continues her
descent until 1890 landing has reached
the video feed jerks and the subject
yells D 9 double 8 for almost fell to a
hole in the ground
video feed confirms the presence of a
hole approximately 1 meter in diameter
the subject shines the floodlight down
revealing only blackness approximately
four seconds passed and a light of
indeterminate distance down the hole
flex on for approximately two seconds
and then back off do you know a double 8
four notes that she sees the light but
she can't see it anymore she also notes
it was at least a kilometer away and
finally notes that the child still
sounds far away is by being 89 floors
down D 9 double 8 for continues to
descend SCP 87 for approximately 1 hour
covering an additional 164 flights
she stops to rest on the 250 third
landing consuming one nutrient bar and
several gobs of water D 9 double 8 4 is
that an estimated 1.1 kilometers below
the initial landing yet the sound of the
child has not changed in volume after
pausing for four minutes d 9 double a
full resumed her descent making no stops
for another 216 flights one and a half
hours later D 9 double a four is on the
469 landing
an approximate one point eight
kilometers below the ground level d9
double eight four reports feeling
frustrated at this point saying I'm not
getting anywhere I think it's time I
went back I mean going down is one thing
but this is a long climb back control
informs her that she has been provided
with food water and blankets the last
her 24 hours and - please continue down
subject refuses says she is going back
up
d9 double 8 4 turns toward the previous
flight of stairs at this point Deana and
uh blade 4 is heard to be screaming in
terror SCP 87 - 1 the face is directly
behind d9 double 8 for blocking her
ascent the face appears approximately 30
centimeters from the lens of the camera
its eyes are fixed directly on the lens
this time looking not at the subject but
the person viewing the video feed the
video feed glitches and freezes for 4
seconds accompanied by a static like
screeching noise from the audio feed it
then cuts to bumpy visuals of d9 double
8 for descending the stairs rapidly at
this point d9 double 8 4 is absolutely
hysterical panicking saying that SCP 87
- one is following her this whole time
it's been right behind me pleading for
help from control this goes on for quite
a while it's quite unsettling to listen
to d9 double a for continues to scream
and plead hysterically as she rapidly
descends the staircase the previously
heard static like screeching seems to
overlay the audio feed beneath which can
still be heard the original sound of the
crying child approximately 14 flights
down the video feed swings to show the
area directly behind Deana and double-a
for the face is now approximately 20
centimeters from the camera lens it is
not staring at the subject rather it is
fixated on the camera lens giving the
illusion it's making eye contact with
those viewing the footage it is
important to note that since the
sighting of SCP 87 - 1 the sound of the
girl crying and pleading has been
increasing in volume indicating d9
double 8 4
is nearing the source after an
approximate 150 panic flights of descent
with three visual confirmations of a CP
87 - one still in pursuit
d9 double 8:1 trips and appears to fall
unconscious audio feed indicates strong
proximity to the source of the crime a
static and screeching noise continue
video feed shows yet another descending
flight of stairs indicating d9 double 84
has still not reached the base of the
stairwell 12 seconds of motionlessness
pass before the face comes in full view
of the camera eye contact being made
directly with the viewer audio and video
feed cuts out and no connection is
re-established as I've said document 4
has been expunged by the higher-ups
and this concludes our lesson for today
thank you very much for listening you
are dismissed
[Music]
you